bom dia a todos
quando eu comecei a pensar em qual linha
seguir para abordar o tema da sua
palestra
eu pensei principalmente em como eu vou
prender a atenção das pessoas para
abordar um tema que aparentemente todo
mundo já sabe
eu já convivi é que são os sons da
cidade
então há como urbanista eu pensei em
falar um pouquinho sobre percepção
urbana e como professora eu pensei em
falar um pouquinho sobre como a nova
geração parece cada vez menos
interessada em compreender o espaço da
cidade
mas o que tudo isso tem a ver com os
sons da cidade
na verdade a gente só consegue acessar
nossa noção de cidade a noção que a
gente constrói sobre cidade através da
compreensão dos nossos sentidos
então um gosto tatu avisam que é muito
importante e também a audição fazem
parte dessa compreensão que a gente
constrói sobre a nossa noção de cidade a
nação que a gente forma sobre a cidade e
esse tema dos sons da cidade ele na
verdade é muito pouco abordado em
pesquisa científica porque a gente
consegue encontrar muito mais pesquisas
que abordam a questão dos sons enquanto
um problema social e essa questão dos
problemas que são gerados pelos sons na
cidade estão relacionados então a temas
como poluição sonora ruídos o tráfego
níveis de ruído isso sim a gente
consegue encontrar numa maior quantidade
mas eu não quero ficar aqui falando
sobre problemas a gente quer falar sobre
coisas boas aqui no ted né
e a gente pode então a pensar que os
sons da cidade eles são chamados assim
principalmente porque não só porque eles
são projetados na cidade porque eles são
produzidos na cidade mas também porque
eles são sentidos na cidade e eles obtêm
significado a partir das experiências
que a gente adquire na cidade e isso tem
a ver então um todo esse significado que
a gente atribui aos
sons que a gente escuta e é a maneira
como a gente atribui esses significados
que constitui o que a gente pode chamar
de paisagem sonora
essa paisagem então ela só vai ser
construída por nós à medida que a gente
vai conseguir adquirir e atribuir
significados aos sons ea maneira como a
gente andar esse significado para o som
está muito relacionado amplo por exemplo
a maneira como a gente atribui a uma
questão emotiva ao som som que a gente
atribui a felicidade ou por exemplo um
som que a gente atribui concede ali a um
lugar como por exemplo são da praia ea
gente pode pensar também ano vínculo que
a gente faz quando a gente pensa no som
aliado a uma atividade que a gente
realiza no nosso dia a dia como por
exemplo o som do trabalho
essas todas são questões da incluindo
maneira como a gente incorpora o som na
nossa rotina né
e isso tem a ver então com essa nossa
prática cotidiana que é uma das maneiras
como a gente consegue compreender e
entender o espaço da cidade
então o som está sempre ligado e
vinculado a uma questão de sentido são
as pessoas que dão sentido aos sons e
esse sentido está sempre relacionado e
atribuído a um escopo que a gente tem da
nossa cultura
se a gente considerar que o som só vai
ter sentido e o sentido que a gente vai
atribuir o som para construir o espaço
da cidade esse espaço da percepção do da
cidade como um todo que é baseado na
nossa cultura a gente tem que entender
que tudo que a gente já viveu já
vivenciou na nossa vida
todas as experiências pelas quais a
gente já passou influenciam diretamente
na maneira como a gente percebe esse som
e portanto na maneira como a gente
constrói esse espaço da cidade
isso é importante porque a maneira como
a gente se relaciona então com a cidade
tem muito a ver com todas essas
experiências anteriores que a gente já
teve na nossa vida por exemplo
senti um carro de corrida de fórmula 1
ou o ruído do tráfego do trânsito não
pode ser muito prazeroso para algumas
pessoas um determinado momento mas se a
gente está envolvido no tráfego urbano
na vida da cidade pode ser muito
irritante né
assim como por exemplo sou um passarinho
não é que num determinado momento se a
gente está no ambiente urbano caótico o
idoso escutar o som do passarinho pode
nos remeter aquela sensação super
agradável de um contato com a natureza e
tudo mais mas em outro momento a gente
pode pensar aqui pode ser muito
irritante também escutar o som de um
passarinho se o que a gente quer é
dormir ou estudar e isso é importante
porque nos leva a 22 pensamentos o
primeiro que a gente está o tempo
inteiro sendo submetido a ruidosa fontes
de ruído e segundo que na verdade todas
essas fontes o sonoras né as quais a
gente está sendo submetido na verdade
podem funcionar como uma espécie de
barreira a gente tem as paredes da nossa
casa que funcionam muito como uma
barreira visual mas elas não impedem ou
não funcionam como um limite para o som
e quando a gente pensa nisso a gente
pode pensar então imediatamente que a
gente é o tempo inteiro sendo submetido
a fontes sonoras e esse pensamento anos
leva a crer que a gente tá então a
maneira como a gente escolhe se
locomover na cidade por exemplo é uma
fonte de ruído a gente escolhe sair de
casa um determinado meio de transporte
que é ruim idoso o a caminhada as
pessoas na rua provoca ruídos
o salto da vizinha do apartamento de
cima provoca ruídos o todo e qualquer
meio de transporte então provoca ruídos
e bem questões mais positivas como por
exemplo a gente escutar o barulho da
chuva num determinado momento os
passarinhos cantando em outros momentos
não falhar das folhas com o vento a
gente chega no local de trabalho escuta
o tempo inteiro cuida do computador por
exemplo de gado acionar
a gente chega lá em casa e escuro até o
ruído barulho da respiração de alguém né
pode ser vinculado não é esse
esse monte de fontes sonoras e os quais
a gente está exposto o tempo inteiro na
vida na cidade
hoje em dia a gente está muito vinculado
à questão das novas tecnologias na a
gente tá tempo inteiro com gadgets aqui
totalmente conectados na alguma a uma
outra fonte
e isso é uma questão totalmente nova
para a gente né
é interessante a gente pensar então como
muitas vezes a gente consegue mesmo
estando tão conectados abstrair algumas
dessas todas essas fontes que a gente
está submetido ea gente consegue fazer
uma seleção não é uma seleção
psicológica na sobreposição de todas
essas fontes que a gente está submetido
a gente consegue eu encontrar uma um
local de equilíbrio que se chama uma
onda estacionário né e essa onda
estacionária justamente aquela onda
intermediária que é a seleção
psicológica que a gente faz o tipo de
ruído que a gente quer na verdade escuta
naquele momento
isso é importante porque quando a gente
pensa então nessa presença múltipla dos
sons da cidade
a gente pode destacar o papel que esses
sons têm na maneira como a gente
apreende o espaço urbano que quer
aprender a captar esse espaço que nos
rodeia né entender esse espaço que nos
rodeia e essa ciência é bastante
estudada e existe um livro muito
emblemático pra isso que se chama imagem
da cidade no autor superconhecido ano no
mundo inteiro que se chama kevin lynch
assim o link aborda quando trata da
cidade a algumas questões então que
estão relacionadas à maneira como a
gente compreende o espaço urbano a
partir do sentido e especialmente da
visão e essa é uma das grandes críticas
que se faz o trabalho do link que é o
quanto ele carece na incorporação de
outras faculdades como por exemplo a
audição na maneira como a gente
compreende então esse espaço urbano
a maneira como a gente leu o espaço da
cidade essa legitimidade do espaço está
diretamente relacionada uma coisa que a
gente chama de cognição espacial que é
esse aprendizado do espaço a partir da
maneira como a gente consegue entender
se locomover ler e usar a cidade como um
todo
então eu convido todo mundo a pensar no
seu trajeto diário que todo mundo faz
aqui tendo como origem a sua casa e como
destino o seu local de trabalho né
todo mundo tem essa memória construído
esse é o meu trajeto casa trabalho a
gente sabe que sai de casa da obra
direito uma vez da obra direito através
e a gente consegue formar na memória
todo esse trajeto né e concebe isso a
gente já aprendeu isso mas esse trajeto
e essa memória só vão ser só vai ser
completa à medida que a gente incorpora
junto com esse sentido visual todos os
outros sentidos inclusive a importância
da audição e esses novas tecnologias que
se incorporam ano nosso dia a dia estão
nos levando a passar por um processo de
mudança na maneira como a gente constrói
todo esse cenário e essa memória
isso é importante porque se forma uma
coisa que a gente chama de dia de
atitude blasé
eu tenho visto muito isso em sala de
aula os alunos chegam os seus fones de
ouvido passar um dia inteiro com a
cabeça baixa e dedilhando seu telefone
celular antes mesmo de ela terminar já
estão com fone de ouvido novamente pra
enfrentar a volta pra casa né ea
essência da atitude blasé é consiste num
poder que a gente chama de discriminação
quer dizer não é que as pessoas que as
coisas ao redor ea cidade não seja
percebida pela por essa nova geração de
atitude blasé significa que na verdade
as coisas são vistas mas tudo a tudo é
concedido um significado assim como se
fosse plano homogêneo nada tem
hierarquia uma coisa não é mais
importante do que a outra
e essa é uma questão então que a eu
encontrar uma característica muito das
grandes
porque nas grandes cidades que a gente
tem uma grande quantidade de estímulos
aos quais a gente está submetido ao
contrário de uma cidade pequena onde
essa velocidade da cidade não é tão
grande a gente tem uma maior qualidade
de vida e essa é uma característica
bastante preocupante porque a gente não
sabe como é que vai ser a repercussão
disso pra essa nova geração de jovens de
atitude blaser né e como é que esses
jovens vão passar a adquirir as memórias
da cidade que a gente tem construídas na
que a gente lembra que a gente constrói
no nosso legal na nossa a vivência e
também como a gente viu nas nossas
experiências anteriores baseadas em
cultura né
como é que tudo isso faz sentido para a
gente construir uma memória a gente não
sabe qual vai ser a repercussão então de
tudo isso para essa nova geração
esse fato fica reforçado bem reforçada
hoje em dia pelas buscas constantes que
a gente faz de endereços na no telefone
celular porque isso é importante a gente
confia tanto no aplicativo que tem uma
busca de um exemplo de uma busca de
endereços né
a gente confia tanto no aplicativo que a
gente utiliza para fazer essa busca todo
mundo aqui faz essa pesquisa de
origem-destino ea gente deixa de
perceber todas essas pistas e orientação
às dicas né que a cidade nos dá pra se
orientar no espaço então cada vez menos
não só essa nova geração mas todos nós
estamos envolvidos num processo de
deixar de olhar para a cidade de deixar
entender a cidade e deixar de se
encantar com a cidade como um todo
então se a gente pode pensar que o som
pode auxiliar de alguma maneira nessa
compreensão da paisagem urbana por outro
lado essa atitude blaser né
pode ter uma consequência muito sério né
pra essas novas gerações aí em nova york
foi proposta uma multa para pedestres
que forem pegos atravessando a rua
falando ao telefone celular ou com os
fones de ouvido
embora a principal motivação para isso
seja justo também
é evitar acidentes com pedestres
a gente pode pensar que a a serenidade
auditiva que é o termo que se usa
proporcionada pelos gadgets possa passar
a influenciar menos né
na maneira como a gente percebe a cidade
então isso pode ser uma iniciativa e
lepra a se lidar com esse tipo de
problema
então quando a gente considera a
sonoridade como uma parte integrante do
nosso dia a dia a gente pode pensar a
audição enquanto uma das possibilidades
de se efetivar todas essas experiências
urbanas
a gente está no local super cheio de
gente num bar por exemplo né ea gente
está exposto a uma série de fontes de
ruído neste momento não é o que a gente
faz na verdade neste momento é focar
naquela conversa que a gente deseja
ouvir e isso é interessante porque a
gente consegue então fazer um mecanismo
de seleção psicológica é que funciona
como esse filtro não é para todas essas
fontes esses estímulos aos quais a gente
está submetido
porque isso é importante porque na
verdade isso também é uma maneira da
gente ter uma atitude blasé que essa
idéia da gente filtrar algumas coisas a
gente quer ouvir e outras coisas a gente
não quer ouvir
e tudo isso é importante para essa
compreensão então da cidade como um todo
esses elementos então e não visuais do
espaço urbano quando a gente compreende
que eles fazem parte sim da noção que a
gente tem na formação da memória de uma
cidade na formação a dessa construção
não é que a gente tem do espaço urbano
a gente pode reconhecer que sim parte da
nossa experiência urbana é a sonora
nesse sentido então pra a finalizar não
é tanto a minha veia urbanismo é quanto
à minha veia professora espera que todos
nós passemos a perceber mais o espaço da
cidade ano se importar mais com o espaço
da cidade a a ver a entender e
principalmente a ouvir todas
suas dicas de orientação é que os sons
da cidade nos dão pra gente conseguir
então formar mais memórias visuais e
ainda eu posso dizer que se a gente se a
nossa memória nossa percepção é
totalmente alterada na em função das
experiências anteriores que a gente
adquire eu posso dizer que a minha
experiência vai se alterar dentro em
breve com a chegada da minha filha que
vai mudar essa noção então que eu tenho
de formação de memórias nem a respeito
dos espaços então muito obrigado foi uma
satisfação